now that you've lied to the police what
are you gonna do I'm going to Disney
World a mom who faked her own kidnapping
and went to Disney World Is Now facing
fraud charges for ripping off her
employer Bonnie Sweden first rose to
Fame in 2009 when she engineered a
kidnapping hoax Sweden called 9-1-1 and
said that she and her daughter had been
carjacked by two black men she claimed
to be calling from the trunk of the
kidnapper's car this triggered a massive
Manhunt and one day later authorities
found out that Sweden and her daughter
were actually hanging out at a luxury
resort at Walt Disney World in Orlando
now Sweden eventually was sentenced to
nine months in jail for the hoax but she
wasn't done criming in 2012 she stole
over 1 million dollars while working as
paralegal she was sentenced to 100
months in federal prison for her crimes
her latest problem arose when she
allegedly stole from an excavating
company where she had worked as a
bookkeeper since 2017. Sweden allegedly
stole checks which she then fraudulently
endorsed over to herself she's charged
with two counts of wire fraud and if
convicted Sweden faces a maximum of 40
years in prison I mean if you can't
trust someone who has engaged in decades
of fraud who can you trust